My philosophy is exactly the title of that book. I know what my patient's fighting cancer.
I think that's a wrong attitude to have right off the bat. This whole thing about we're
going to fight this cancer. I'm going to win it. I'm going to win this battle. I just
think that your body is making all those corners all. You're at a sympathetic state. Your
parasympathetics are shut down. Your immune system is suppressed. Wrong attitude. You got
to go, okay, I got cancer. What's the smartest thing to do? We're supposed to call for wisdom
first. Ask for wisdom of the right reason. It's promised to give us that wisdom. Whether
we walk in that wisdom. Okay, you're dealing with this bump in the road. You got cancer.
And it might even take your life. If this is your time to go, it's going to take your life.
And I can't even stand in the way of that. What are you going to do about it? Make sure you
make peace with God in the process. So you know where you're going when you're good. But
we just got to be wise in everything that we do. So I want my patients living. I don't
want them. We do a modified gursal approach with every one of our patients too. You guys know
what gursal therapy is? We do not do a full gursal approach. Make it a juice every hour on
the hour while you're awake and while you're up during the day and then five coffee at
them as a day. I'm not living that way. I'd rather die. So I don't want my patients living
that way either. So I want them living. I want them going back and getting their job
back. I want them playing with their grandkids. You know, pouring your life into other people's
life. And let's treat you while you're sleepy. Yes, there's some things that you got to do
during the day. Absolutely. So typically when we see a patient, you want to find out what
the cause is. So in my book, this is my important thing. You got to find out what the cause
is. Because if you could find out what the cause is and get rid of that cause, you're at
least on your road to recovery. For instance, if the cause of my liver cancer here is from
a vaccine that I had, the MMR vaccine that I had when I was three years old and whatever
toxin that was in there is causing the liver cells to constantly be replicated. I want
to do something to get rid of that toxin. Typically, that's when we go back to a key later if
it's something like that. I want to key that out. So that I don't, even though I can wave
a magic wand over my liver, the liver cancer goes away. If I don't get rid of the cause,
that could be a cause of another primary side cancer someplace else through three years
though the road. So finding the cause to me is really important. It's not always necessary
to kill the cancer, but it's important. Second, we have to find out what specifically in my
book, neutrosutically, will help kill that cancer. So neutrosutically means different specific
nutrients. There's a lot of different cancer killers. If you do read my book, stop finding cancer,
I have to clarify something. In that book, I go through a whole mess of different nutrients
and cancer killers. And in that book, I even say, if you have cancer, you should be on this.
If you have cancer, you should be on this. If you have cancer, you should be on this. But I wrote that book
for people who will never be able to come to me. In reality, I test the person everything. Go back
to that liver detox pathway, understanding you do not want to overwhelm the liver detox pathways.
I'm anybody, let alone somebody that has cancer. So I take a very minimalistic approach to
neutrosuticals as well. Even though I know a lot about nutrition. I have a lot of coursework and
studies and letters behind my name about nutrition. You do not want to overwhelm the liver detox pathways.
Even with good things and patients with cancer, typically coming with a basketball stuff. But I
let sent me this and said that this works and my brother sent me this and my friends sent me this.
All very good, well-meeting things. And those are all good things, maybe, even. They're great things. I read
a book on protocell. So I started taking protocell. I read the hoxy book. So I started taking this
and SEX. So I love this, I love this. If you take too many things, you overwhelm the liver and you are
not going to get better. So I use, typically, my cancer patients are literally on one or two or three
things. Number one, you want to fight out with a cause. Pull that out. Number two, you want to fight out
neutrosutically. What's going to kill that rapidly, replicated as fast as fast as possible. That's where
you've got to have a lot of different tools in your tool bag. A lot of different neutrosuticles
from a lot of different places that have different, you know, all those things work. But what's going to work
on me? And then, what are the RIF programs that we're going to use exactly?